il parcourt les rues de chennai aux
quatre coins de la ville avec son
toughbook arul rage garde un oeil sur
les habitants il est le fondateur d'un
organisme dette sociale avec une mission
bien précise se courir les sans abri
principalement les personnes âgées et
veillez à ce qu'elle soit prise en
charge et transférées vers un logement
ça nous prend des sdf dans les rues
nous leur parlons vérifions leurs
besoins et les aidons à mener une vie
digne
je suis un conducteur de tout tout vous
avez trouvé des gens comme ça je vais
leur parler et leur demander pourquoi
ils sont dans la rue ils racontent leur
histoire et j'essaie de les persuader de
rester dans des refuges
pendant cette période particulière de
pandémie la prise en charge des
personnes vulnérables est aussi médical
une ambulance peut intervenir tester
diagnostics sont réalisés sur place
si le résultat est positif la personne
est transféré vers un hôpital pour
accomplir cette tâche
arul rage sainthood une large équipe de
bénévoles environ 500 volontaires
travaillent avec nous à jeûner pour
aider ces personnes vulnérables
notre objectif est que personne n'ait à
vivre dans la rue comme ici les
volontaires se coordonnent avec nous
dans toute la ville et nous informe
chaque fois qu'ils trouvent des
personnes qui ont besoin d aide
après je viens les rencontrer
depuis 2015 arul rage sert de la
nourriture aux personnes dans le besoin
par le biais de dons ou de financement
participatif avec l'aide de la police
locale son initiative a permis d'aider
plus de 1300 personnes à retrouver un
logement même si certains sans abri
refuse d'être déplacés dans cette
période critique pour l'inde en raison
de la pandémie le travail d'art ouvrage
prend une autre dimension